many people think of Sciences a
political concerned with facts not
political views values or opinions
however when it comes to science-based
policy and legislation science no longer
seems unbiased the prevalence of
opinions and biases and policy debates
has led countless members of the
scientific community to avoid policy
debates despite their ability to provide
helpful contributions
however science and politics are more
intertwined than most people realize
science helps lawmakers write policies
and regulations that affect our everyday
lives at the same time government shape
science through budgets laws and
regulations using NASA the National
Aeronautics and Space Administration as
an example let's walk through how our
federal policies have shaped research in
2018 Congress provided NASA with an
annual operating budget of sixteen point
five billion dollars why did the federal
government invest so heavily in NASA's
research first public demand for
scientific research can strongly
influence politicians motivated by
increasing public concern lawmakers have
funded research to investigate climate
changes causes and mitigate its effects
this research is closely tied to NASA's
work in outer space satellites monitor
Earth's atmosphere and solar panels
which power most spacecraft are an
emerging alternative to fossil fuels
Congress also funds research because it
recognizes the potential for research to
have broad societal impacts in
unexpected ways as a result many
groundbreaking technologies like GPS and
advanced prosthetic limbs have their
roots in NASA technology second global
competition and national Security's
concerns motivate federal funding for
NASA the space race which was one of the
many arenas in which the United States
and the Soviet Union fought the Cold War
assured in NASA's growth
after the Soviet Union shocked the
United States by building Sputnik the
world's first orbiting spacecraft NASA's
successful moon landing in 1969 restored
national pride and garnered
international recognition NASA has also
developed numerous military aviation
technologies like composite materials
fly-by-wire cockpits and wing tip
winglets that were later adapted for
commercial aircraft government
priorities shift with time and this is
reflected in NASA's budget for example
near the height of the space race in
1966 the fraction of the federal budget
dedicated to NASA was almost ten times
as large as it is today by contrast
adjusted for today's dollars the
National Institute of Health's budget
grew threefold between 1970 in 2005 now
let's examine how science influences
policy many beneficial laws like the
Clean Air Act of 1970 have been the
result of scientific research and
scientists are frequently consulted as
experts when bills are drafted
scientific research also serves as the
basis for entire federal institutions
like the Department of Energy which
regulates nuclear material and funds
energy related research as we can see
scientific research shapes policy and
vice-versa every generation has new
challenges that need scientific
solutions ensuring that our nation's
students are provided the education and
training to meet these challenges both
through science and policy is crucial to
the success of our nation and the world
you